we're looking at factorizing expressions
and this is what we started yesterday
okay we're going to dig back into it and
have a look at some trickier examples so
first let's just remember these things
here if you didn't see any word that
told you what to do with these right
what would you guess that you should do
with this it is just yeah
okay so let's see we're good River right
we will look at this under the heading
of expanding expanding expressions right
and we say well there's five times X are
there Rachel it will be five times six
because there's really our
multiplication so hiding in there is it
there and that multiplication gets
distributed with the whole distributive
law idea across to other two numbers so
what is five by six
it's 30 right good okay so we remember
that this process of going from left to
right is what we call expanding its
varied and if you were to go in reverse
that's what we call factoring in
factorizing is going this way both of
these terms on the right hand side right
both these herbs have 5 as a factor okay
so if I saw not this question but this
question right if I saw this
okay well the first question the word
might have been experienced and on this
question but where might be factorized
right so you really got to pay attention
to his verbs they tell you here's a
situation but what do you do with them
okay so just like we did this in Reverse
you see or look there's a five that I
could divide both of these numbers by
right so this is in fact the way that I
would take I would put a five at the
front and I'd say right well would I
divide this by 5 what am I left with
heads-up X when I divide this by 5 what
do I get left with it's a six right so
that was us going in the reverse
direction
okay now Silla was here that's ok take a
second you can you can tell me that have
a look at this let's do the expansion do
the expansion okay what am I going to
get when I distribute this 4 across to
the other two terms it's 5 4 times 3x
what will I get on X 12 X very good
4 times 7 run bloody there great job ok
now I picked this one out cuts a little
bit trickier suppose they're just like
here we got not this is a question but
this was the question ok so you see 12x
plus 28 and then they said okay to
factorize okay it example we looked at
just a minute ago this one it's really
easy to see there's going to be a 5
there because there's a 5 there but you
can't do that with this one can you
right 12 goes into this but it doesn't
go into this right you go the multiples
of 12 are 12 and did 24 and then 36 I
missed 28 not in there right it's not a
multiple of 12 so here you'll be really
careful this is what the whole point of
last exercise was when we looked at
highest common factor you have to say
what's the biggest number that I could
divide both of these by
the biggest elbow okay now remember we
just expanded this right this is where
it came from
yeah yeah it's gonna be four isn't it
now I'll just give you a quick example
of what happens if you don't spot that
it's four okay just suppose right ah 12
and 28 they're both even numbers right
so I can definitely / - right that's
fine okay
so what will happen when I put a two out
the front I'll divide this by two and
that leaves me with 6x very good and
I'll divide this by two which leaves me
with 14 okay now you pause pause and you
look at what you've written down okay
I've taken out a factor but I can keep
going
can I look 6x + 14 they still have a
common factor that they're still even
out there right so in fact I can take
two out another time so when I take it
up two out it'll be two times two and
then I'll get by three X plus seven
which is a lot of started right by two
times two out the front that's the form
so even if you don't spot it right away
okay you could do it over a couple of
steps and that's still fine okay now
this one's a bit trickier right well we
had a look at these questions I started
with the expansion and then we work
backwards we kind of knew what we were
expected you don't know what to expect
here okay so let's just take this
approach of thinking well what is in
common between these and there's loads
of things
can someone spot just one for me what's
one thing it's definitely in common
between both of these terms yeah but on
okay good I see X's in both of them okay
now watch out there's an x squared here
so how many X's are really there there's
really two there's no power here so how
many X's are there really there's one I
could write one there if I wanted okay
so the first thing I'll do is I'll take
out X that alright yeah
oh good okay I'll get to the number in a
second let's just do one step at a time
okay I'm going to do that we'll do that
next
so I've taken an X out but just like I
took a two out the front or five so when
I take an X out of this what am I left
with just just the number right
72 okay I want to take an X out of this
you told me 30 seconds ago you told me
there were two x's there right so if I
take one away how many left
why but just be the X right with that 48
okay does that make sense you see what
I've done
so I factorized a little bit of taking
our necks but as Rachel mentioned I can
keep going I can take out twelve works
twelve works so I'm going to put a 12 at
the front there was already an X right
and now how do you look at this I'll
divide each of them by twelve 72 divided
by twelve two big dub are pretty sure
it's six six right and you can double
check in six by twelve there's 72 yeah
okay so but there yet look at ya
Arriba I'm trying to train you to see
right
you can all do it in one here I could do
this on one hit because I've seen these
questions before I also wrote this
question so I know what it's gonna be
but you might not see it right away
again that doesn't mean you stock it me
get going
right so I've taken out 12 from this
when I take it we're divided 12
uh-huh right 48 divided by 12 48 oh yeah
join it oh very good
so I've got a plus 4 don't forget
there's an X still hanging around yeah
so far so good
you see that am I done I'm not I can
keep going one more step it looks like
what number shall I take up to 6 and 4
both even so when I multiply this if I
divide this by 2 I'm going to multiply
this by 2 it's kind of like before beds
but it's 24s 3 3
three okay it's alright settle down
divide by six
I'll get three five divided by four
there's my aides okay so some of you
some of the quicker people here and if
you practice these before you would have
noticed right from here right from there
I can take out 24 right because that's
three lots of 24 that's two lots of 24
and I can take out the X if you're
really really good you can go straight
there but most of us it takes a bit of
time and a bit of practice to you'll see
that we make a few steps
no problem just show you working and
you'll be all good okay